Hi everyone!
This is president Barack Obama.
NASA's Aura Satellite has been tracking global pollution trends for the past decade
and it's initial findings have shown us a lot about the state of our atmosphere
The satellite detects gases like nitrogen dioxide,
the common pollutant from cars and power plants,
the data shows us that the United States and Europe have some of the highest emissional levels in the world
But it also shows us that over the last 25 years,
Nitrogen Dioxide levels have dropped by up to 50% in both regions.
Thanks in large part, to new rules that protect our air.
At the same time, in China, India, and the Middle East.
This pollution has grown dramatically
So imagery like this can help us see what actions are working,
and where we need to focus additional international efforts.
and it proves, that we all need to work together
to protect the one planet we've got.
Guys, thanks for watching DNews!
Please take a second, and subscribe.
and also watch President Obama on, "Science Presents: DNews"
every night this week at 9/8 Central on "Science Channel"
Or you can watch them right here, on our youtube page. (music)